un moratoire sur ce qui avait servi de
catalyseur de la grogne la hausse de la
taxe carbone l'objectif immédiat il est
clair faire rentrer les gilet jaune chez
eux et stopper la contagion
alors ces annonces sont elles
suffisantes ou au contraire trop tardive
est donc inaudible
on en débat donc dans un instant mais
l'on regarde d'abord edouard philippe
c'est être matignon tout à l'heure cette
colère il faudrait être sourd ou aveugle
pour ne pas l'avoir dit l'entendre c'est
la colère de la france qui travaille qui
travaille dur et qui peinent à joindre
les deux bouts
la colère des français qui sont le dos
au mur celle aussi des mères de familles
qui élèvent seules leurs enfants
convaincant écoutez je vous savez que
souvent je suis un petit peu critique
franchement techniquement c'est un très
bon discours enfin je veux dire il coche
quand même je dis bien techniquement
après je pense que autour du de ces
tabliers des biens meilleurs
spécialistes politiques
il est un excellent discours d'abord
idées bref il pourrait donner ce conseil
de brièveté qui vous savez il est bref
or tous les discours de crise doivent
être bref c'est une loi rappelez-vous de
gaulle en 68 chez chronométrait de
gaulle à 68 2 minutes 40 et 1 million
personnes dans la rue il est vrai qu'il
est très clair il n'y a pas un mot
techno d'ailleurs le même même le mot
moratoire que les journalistes utilisent
ils ne l'emploie pas il parle de
suspendre et il est très clair il suit
en plus un magnifique rythme ternaire 1
2 3 1 2 3 tout ça est excellent il donne
l'impression pas de d'expédier un peu le
côté bon vous l'a compris on a entendu
la grogne est très clair on n'est pas
une telle taxe ne mérite pas que le pays
se déchire tout tout est très clair
son message encore une fois je laisse
les autres commenter sur le fond et son
message est très clair je crois que ces
arguments fin des mesures qu'il prend
sont claires il ne dit pas contrairement
à ce qu'on entend partout que la taxe
sera de toute façon appliquée au bout de
six mois au contraire
il ouvre mais on entend des commentaires
il ouvre une perspective même de
suppression maintenant deux questions
est-ce que ce n'est pas tout l'être
comme disent nos amis anglais et est ce
que ce n'est pas quelqu'un d'autre qui
vous pouvez deviner de tenir un discours
de finale sur cette question de chez les
jaunes ça ne peut pas être que le
premier ministre sait où je ferai un
discours très clair et bien et c'est un
7 1 rue de paris quand même cette
affaire d'edouard philippe ont d'abord
il manque complètement son chapeau
melman je vais classe il faut bien le
dire ce qui quand on doit manger son
chapeau qui vers la tour que j'ai un
trauma ce qu'il avait passé sa vie à
dire j'assume c'est comme ça et pas
autrement nous ne reculerons pas ce pays
crève de ne pas avoir eu la constance
dans les réformes etc
on peut sortir 15 déclarations d'
edouard philippe et donc c'était mines
amant méritoire évidemment de dire
aujourd'hui que bon bah il faut tenir
compte
la découverte de la vie quotidienne des
français et des françaises est un peu
tardif pour l'ensemble de la macro ni je
pense que nous en parlerons peut-être
parce que c'est très sympathique de
parler de cette france qui travaille dur
qui se lève tôt de ces mères de familles
qui élèvent seules les enfants il va
peut-être fallu y penser avant de
bouleverser la vie quotidienne des gens
car c'est ça qu'ils reprochent le risque
mais c'est un premier tour de table que
vous faites donc nous y reviendrons le
risque c'est à la fois trop et trop peu
trop peu parce que les gens n'attendent
pas on leur dise on verra les choses
dans six mois est trop parce qu'il a
étendu à l'électricité au gaz est un
ensemble de choses qui fait que si doit
céder définitivement vouloir céder sur
tout et pas seulement sur la taxe
carburant
fallait il à ce point élargir jeu made
est la question l'idée du hamel deux
choses ce que nous digérons déjà prêts à
la fois découverte un peu tardive de la
vie quotidienne des français est trop et
trop peu à la fois bon les jets
relativement jusque dit jérôme jaffré
saluer relativement pourri mais ça lui
coûte ça lui coûte
vous pouvez pas y aller donc ce que je
vais dire est relativement exagéré mais
je pense que l'heure n'est pas à la
critique
je pense que il ya tellement
d'irresponsabilité généralisée dans du
coton sur le thème trop tôt trop tard
trop trop peu de toutes parts
du côté des politiques enfin de toutes
les oppositions quelle qu'elle soit
qu'importe ce qui abîme le pays
pourvu que cela affaiblisse le pouvoir
dans une situation comme celle
d'aujourd'hui hier est trop grave
je trouve ça absolument totalement
irresponsable et du côté des gilets
jaunes enfin la plupart d'entre eux
qu'importe les dégâts pourvu que
continue d'une part les bacchanales
local réjouissante et d'autre part les
apparitions médiatiques constante et
bien non il ya un moment où ses
responsabilités et tentait les prenant
une telle ampleur le commentateur doit
dans son analyse me semble-t-il en tout
cas peut en tout cas c'est ce que je
souhaite faire restreindre les bémols
critique et dire que sur l'essentiel le
pouvoir politique a fait d'abord à fait
ce que tout ce que la plupart des gens
étaient là lui demandait à commencer par
alexis brézet relisez sur l'éditorial de
lundi remarqua on va et bien alors
relativement court avant on est d'abord
de re lire l'éditorial d'alexis c'est
prévu on va et vous parliez des
oppositions on va les écouter justement
l on est davantage
très vite l intervention d par philippe
mais ça nous répond pas au mal de vivre
aujourd'hui sa ds et à dire à des gens
qui je vivais encore albert ou al
flixecourt ce week-end ont le sentiment
que la fin de mois est de plus en plus
proche du début du mois nous indique
très clairement que ne changera pas de
cap il nous dit vous voulez plus
écologie alors c'est plus de taxes pour
les moins de taxes alors c'est moins
d'écologie
ensuite il nous dit vous voulez plus de
service public
alors ce sera aussi plus impôts nous
demandons la suppression pure et simple
de ses 46 milliards de taxes
supplémentaires qui s'apprête à faire à
mettre sur le dos des français donc
c'est pas un moratoire c'est pas un
débat c'est quoi une discussion on
demande leur suppression
nous allons gagner un peu de temps avec
une suspension qui permettra d'arriver
jusqu'au lendemain des européennes ce
qui évidemment laisse
suspecté qu'il s'agit là d'une mesure
exclusivement électoraliste
alexis olivier duhamel nous a dit il
faut être sérieux et responsable en
l'occurrence là les oppositions elles
sont irresponsables
une fois n'est pas coutume je suis
absolument d'accord et qu olivier
duhamel bien sûr ça arrive tard au
figaro c'est plein de gens ça fait
quinze jours quand il faut retirer ça
aurait été mieux de le retirer plus tôt
bien sûr on aurait pu se rendre compte
que c'était pas une réforme c'était une
taxe et qu'une taxe ça ça se retire et
puis voilà bon mais enfin on est quand
même c'est vrai qu'on est au bord de la
guerre si la fin des affrontements qui
sont d'une violence et qui deviennent
incontrôlables
il ya ce qu'on a vu dans paris samedi
dernier il ya les lycéens qui s'en mêle
et puis il ya des infirmiers qui s'en
mêle et régler les agriculteurs qui
disent qu'ils vont arriver
et puis et puis et puis ça va s'arrêter
quand donc il ya un moment il faut faire
preuve d'un peu de sérieux
d'autant que c'est vrai que dans
philippe il dit je suspends on en
discute pendant trois mois et si au bout
de trois mois n'est pas ceci - pardon et
surtout si on n'est pas d'accord nous en
tirons l'instant ça veut dire on le
retire c'est un mot pudique c'est une
façon pudique de dire retrait alors
est-ce qu'il fallait avoir cette pudeur
peut-être vu le degré de 2,2
d'exaspération des régions ne peut être
pas peut-être que ce que les jets les
jaunes souhaitez moi au fond je pense
que c'est ça c'est qu'ils veulent que ce
soit emmanuel macron parce que là on est
en train d'envahir les traits d'un truc
irrationnel où ils veulent finalement
une espèce d'humiliation symbolique du
président de la république pour gagner
rien que ça mais pour autant que les
oppositions disent trop peu trop tard
pas maintenant pas comme si pas comme ça
tout le monde pense qu'il faut les
retirer ce truc et leur tir bas 10 ont
déjà au moins ça c'est bien il ya une
inquiétude croissante quand même dans le
pays sur le niveau effectivement de
violence le niveau d'affrontement le
niveau
de cohésion social déchiré dans le pays
et qui fait donc si vous voulez que
logiquement tous ceux qui sont attachés
au bon fonctionnement de la démocratie
peuvent légitimement s'inquiéter
en même temps il ya en face un simplisme
un refus des contraintes qui est quelque
chose de considérable et qui fait donc
on peut pas tellement être dans la
nuance le président de la république la
semaine dernière a fait un discours on
pouvait revenir dessus car c'est l'anti
modèle absolu de ce qu'il faut tenir
comme discours mais je parle sous le
contrôle de christophe de voc qui comme
beaucoup mieux que moi a apprécié et
analyser les discours il avait déjà dit
on va faire trois mois de discussions et
au bout de ces trois mois de discussions
je suis prêt à revoir les solutions
il avait dix salles président dont on
pouvait l'interpréter tout aussi bien
comme au bout de trois mois comme on en
a discuté dans les territoires on
aboutira au fait que cette taxe
carburant n'est pas adapté à la vie
quotidienne des gens ça n'a pas du tout
été entendue comme ça alors que je vois
edouard philippe recommencer et lui pas
se donner trois mois
nommé maintenant mais je termine je veux
mon propos est arrivée la mauvaise je
termine mon propos et puis vous me bats
l'airé après mais je veux on va jusqu'au
bout il dit lui est ce que vient de dire
alexis au mood si on va discuter en fait
on on arrête ça change tout et on a
résumé je suspends donc je n'enlève pas
je ne supprime donc c'est pas la même
chose je sais je suspends et on sait
bien que mâcon c'est sûr c'est pas m
c'est évidemment un pas en avant je
suspends et on discute pendant six mois
et au bout de six mois on ti je tirerai
les conclusions si on n'aime pas se
mettre d'accord ça peut tout aussi bien
être entendu par les exaltés qui sont en
face dans le simplisme et le refus des
contraintes comme j'en tirerai les
conclusions en prenant les décisions que
le gouvernement veut prendre c'est pas
du tout forcément entendu comme les
naïfs que vous êtes le croient comme une
buse qu'on n'est pas d'accord j'y
renoncerait donc le problème c'est je
reviens au remarquable éditorial
d'alexis rezai de lundi étudier c'est il
faut un thème il faut un totem dans la
sphère le totem c'est l'abandon de cette
taxe qu'on doit présenter clairement
c'est pas tout à fait fait c'est ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que 13
ce qu'avait dit ma cour macron il avait
dit on continue les hausses de taxes et
pourtant le lot de 50 par les légendes
espaces verts des crises qu'on regarde
mes garçons comment vous avez convaincu
lundi matin mais oui d'habitation moi
j'ai rien non mais ça c'est de la
rhétorique vous avez quand même con
dallas et c'est populiste bougies les
gens qui est contrôlé ni nobel vous avez
compris ce qu'il voulait dire je veux
dire n'était pas satisfaisant il a dit
aux gens on maintient les taxes et
pendant qu'on applique l'état qui sont
discutées j'en dis non si tu confonds
pas tu arrêtes les taxes c'est ce que
leur dit edouard philippe mais il ne va
pas je suis sur la bonne voie là
jusqu'au bout de l'humiliation 14
avez-vous la réserver à maquereau est en
vol stationnaire le millas à la
conduirons suces quand les charges macro
discutent de mesures d'accompagnement
et si on n'y arrive pas on aborderont la
bande et labadie on n'a pas tari
signalant prendra les mesures qui sont
ils à partir complètement quoi on pas
que je suis et moi excusez moi je moi à
mon avis je pense que l'état se faire
passer pour découvrir ce qu'il joue être
plus méchant spa est parmi les plus cons
loin de là mais je connais je connais
l'opinion publique je connais et je
coûte comme vous sur les chaînes
d'information continue le simplisme le
refus des contraintes
le jusqu'au boutisme l'absence de
sincérité de dialogue qui existe et dont
j'aimais déjà les roms on a ce qu'on
oublie ça peut voir moi j'ai entendu
aussi des gilets jaunes réagir si on
peut parler de gilet jaune dans leur
ensemble
c'est en gros ça nous suffit pas parce
que tu as son il faut taper les riches
je résume très de façon un petit peu
oui aux ailes à l'appel alors c'est vous
qui avez un oui c'est vous qui avez
raison
savoir s'ils ont su stopper le mot est à
ce moment là on abandonnera il aurait il
dit exactement ce qu'on entend mais nous
ce qu'on veut c'est le crissement
clients mais nous ce qu'on veut c'est
l'assemblée si c'est pas fini
oui c'est par exemple l'un d'eux
benjamin cauchy dit on ne veut pas que
des miettes mais la baguette
bon c'est une formule elle est nommée
des prisons de quoi très bons ils ont
elles le gouvernement n'a pas changé de
pied il a juste changé d'orteils je
trouvais ça super tendres pour 70
cacahuètes alors que c'est ce qu'ils
demandent donc qui demandaient des
cacahuètes oui mais ça c'est le prix à
payer aussi pour avoir trop patent
douala plus on attend plus les gens sont
énervés plus éveillés vous ils
continuent de mourir première deux ans à
la bio est ce que c'est de nature à
calmer mais je pense que c'est aussi la
traduction du fait que l'intérieur même
du mouvement des jeunes
une évolution qui s'est produite dans le
temps c'est que au départ aurait suffi
rouge à 10,31 points qui fonctionnaires
y en a marre de l'état foutez nous la
paix laissez nous travailler le figaro
d'ailleurs à ce moment-là peut-être à
ces imams le dégât est malgré lui
déplaisent comprenez cassant nombre de
gens disent on a trop d'un pont ont peu
fait pour les impôts mais dès le début
je dis je suis parmi mon les approches
ne considère pas qu'il augmente les
impôts soit une réforme votée après
c'est au mieux un mal nécessaire mais ce
n'est pas une info bon en tout cas donc
au début c'est ça et puis ça va se
dépasser petit à petit parce que je
pense qu'elle semble de deux militants
de plus en politique et parce qu'ils
savent connaissent le job vont prendre
le pouvoir et ça va passer de ce jeu 10
mais c'est pas péjoratif rango va trop
d'impôts trop taxe fichez nous la paix à
un truc de plus en plus politique avec
de plus en plus forme de mélenchonistes
qui sont aux manettes
après la question c'est les gens sur les
sionistes et le pq et le pénis mais le
côté là un peu grillé ce qui ce que ce
qu'on voit quand même droit dans le sud
est
c'est le pénis donc c'est normal les
militants paul ribaud la plus le temps
passe plus les militants politiques
s'imposent dans une démarche politique
c'est ils connaissent le job ils savent
le faire après la question c'est sur les
ronds-points comment ça va se passer
est-ce que les laits gilet jaune vont se
dire bon en gros on a ce qu'on voulait
pas exactement mais bon puis c'est noël
maintenant ça va bien
faire froid ou bien il fait pas très bon
ou bien est ce qu'ils vont dire non
voilées plus loin on veut l'humiliation
des manuels macro qui nous a pas
entendus il va falloir qu'ils viennent à
canossa
c'est possible alors on a beaucoup parlé
aussi du soutien des français et
peut-être que l'un se nourrit de l'autre
les gilet jaune se sentant même
conforter dans leurs opérations
on a posé la question depuis ce matin
sur lefigaro.fr après l'annoncé d'un
moratoire lé gilet jaune doivent-ils
cesser leur mouvement
il ya une légère majorité d'entre vous
c'est une question pas un sondage qui
dit oui c'est vrai c'est un enjeu
absolument fondamental c'est à dire que
le gouvernement est d aller gilet jaune
en face mais le vrai élément clé c'est
l'opinion publique selon les sondages
c'est un mouvement qui est fondée si
vous voulez réseaux sociaux chaîne
d'information continue sondages
d'opinion c'est le triptyque qui fondent
le trépied qui fonctionne dans là dedans
c'est parce que les sondages ont montré
premièrement un très fort soutien au
mouvement des gilets jaunes
deuxièmement la stupéfaction du pouvoir
une progression du soutien au gilet
jaune après les manifestations et les
violences
un maintien dans le sondage réalisé
dimanche après les invraisemblables
violences de samedi un maintien que le
gouvernement s'est retrouvé acculé
donc la question c'est après ce que
vient de dire edouard philippe qui sont
quand même des concessions non
négligeable évidemment même je trouve à
certains égards trop de concessions
d'ailleurs puisqu'il a et à l'élargir à
l'électricité et au gaz et bien est-ce
que les onze allons avoir un glissement
comme l'indiquent le figaro tv mais vous
n'êtes pas encore parfaitement
représentatif de la population tourisme
excusez moi je vous le dire c'est les
voilà on sait qu'on voit pas
généralement on arrête c'est là où
l'adhésion enfin où le mouvement était
tellement massif
quand on demandait aux internautes du
figaro.fr est-ce que vous souhaitez noir
et pour des 80% grosso modo comme les
français qui va être à 60 ans voilà mes
2 81% donc là on est passé de 80 % qui
soutenait le mouvement à 54% qui disent
qu'ils font ça mais pas non plus
c'est pas mal c'est 1 81% et sa baisse
un peu d'argent je reconnais absolument
étonnant qui fait juste après juste
après les violences semblent se
reconnaît assez étonnant je pense que ça
démontre ah oui je pense que s'il avait
été fait deux ou trois jours après à
supposer que felipe parler plus tard ça
n'aurait pas été le même résultat si je
pense que la prise de conscience et de
l'ampleur non mais je vous assure
écoutez il ya une option des trucs gens
qui ont regardé les chaînes d'info par
exemple beaucoup d'accords c'est à dire
que si vous évaluez dans la journée ça
devait monter à peu près à 4,5 millions
de personnes mais 4,5 millions de
personnes
ça en fait quand même chez les adultes
pas 40 45 qui n'ont pas regardé
il ya eu un temps d'infusion il ya eu la
découverte progressive le soir le
lendemain le l'image l'image ce magasin
rihanna risque de marianne avec avec la
gueule arraché par exemple ça ce sont
des chèques l'impact sur l'opinion mais
qui fait qu'on puisse emprunter à
démontrer moi je crois quand même qu'il
faut il faut toujours garder toujours
même maintenant quand même garder un
esprit d'analysé passé dans le jugement
et se dire que tout de même il s'est
passé quelque chose
il se passe toujours quelque chose de
très important je pense qu'une partie
des gens vont être satisfaits c'est à
dire les gens les plus du début on va
dire allez les gens à un peu bon enfant
qui moi mon avis avait quand même
quelques raisons de râler sur ce qui
n'était pas une réforme mais une taxe
encore une fois la shoah entièrement
d'accord avec avec alex est brisé et qui
n'avait qu'un but fiscal est pas
écologique et on a là on a raconté des
bobards faut quand même bien le dire
pendant des mois aux gens et c'est
prouvé
c'est prouvé même par les rapports de
bercy donc c'est de cela maintenant vont
certainement s'interroger je pense que
moi je pense comme alexis braisé et
aussi en rhétoriciens je pense que le
premier ministre aurait dû aller jusqu'à
l'annoncé de l'arrêt mais et comme blue
3 mais en mettant ça dans un si j'ose
dire dans un plus fort volant sur la
concertation c'est à dire attention on
arrête
mais il faudra bien trouver des sources
de financement et jeu et je mets ça sur
la table de négociations et à mon avis
là il ya un problème des déséquilibres
et là je crois c'est vrai qu'il a un
petit peu raison giroud jaffré la sueur
ou d'un bâtiment rédaction
olivier je donne la parole à nos
internautes qui joue la donne ensuite
jérôme jaffré redonne un peu des
réactions d'internautes parmi lesquels
ya christophe qui nous dit cette annonce
de moratoire est encore un sofa signale
que c'est la rue la force
le chantage qui gagne dans le pays lolo
salue cette belle analyse de jérôme
jaffré alors comme la le commentaire
vient je ne sais pas exactement à
laquelle il faisait référence sans doute
à tout pat ce moratoire est un attrape
nigaud qui se termine juste après les
européennes c'est de l'argument de
marine le pen il se serait pas pour moi
papa tu montes idiot quand même moins
six mois et six mois six mois c'est
grotesque quand même bon c'est la
politique aussi et nicole taper les
riches ne résoudra rien d'abord à quel
niveau étant riche ce qu'il faut c'est
baisser les dépenses publiques qu'at-il
edouard philippe aussi il a dit
attention si vous voulez c'est la ligne
c'est la ligne de bruno le maire je sais
pas si nous avons attendu un petit peu
ça me met à votre chez qui depuis un
moment dit attention il va falloir
passer il a dit encore hier aussi devra
passer à un nouveau mac ont jusqu'à
présent fou quand même bien le dire ces
augmentations des dépenses augmentation
des impôts depuis 18 mois tu as deux
puits depuis qu'il était conseiller
économique de françois hollande
et là il va falloir passer à diminution
des dépenses et des missions des impôts
je rappelle et le programmes des manuels
macron auquel curieusement ce cap là
personne ne le lui rappellent jamais il
avait dit au départ qu'il diminuerait
les dépenses et les impôts
ce cas n'est pas du tout au bout de 18
mois tous les chiffres du budget d'un
cour des comptes ce cap il ne le tient
pas et j'ai remarqué que la personne
dans l arm permis le soutien de macron
de lui reproche on s'est dit qu'on
allait aussi parlé à prendre un petit
peu de recul séquence impulse a parlé de
l'échec du maquereau nisme point
d'interrogation
bon ces trois dernières semaines elles
peuvent effacer ou non
un an et demi maintenant des manuels
macro